and that previous will live nowhere
dying of thirst everything's [ __ ] I'm
just looking for some place to spend the
night and and I was hoping you can see
her tonight
really
she's actually going on huh
okay well this is not my decision
Oh what he wants blood that's all he's
interested in okay spirits don't live in
this world
if he's here there's a reason - welcome
to beyond 2 souls we just find another
spirit out in the desert is another
weird coincident and now we're gonna
[ __ ] with it probably so we're friends
right
I don't like you Jody don't put my foot
in the stirrup and climb up okay so she
literally broke their yarn and barn or
whatever and they not peace already dead
way ahead of you Jody Jew hey what do
you think Ashley if Amy's head care okay
that horse is gonna have to tell me your
secret listen I'm headed over the past
year to tend to churros
you want to come sure yeah I was waiting
for this moment to happen if I
accelerate by holding this button it's
just like riding a motorcycle except
it's a horse
but who's counting again I love to see
in the ring this game that's like so
pretty I love it it really is like an
interactive movie if anything but I wish
there was more interaction in terms of
choices I want I want in a story based
game I want to do a hard decision that's
where I feel like none of them is a good
one and stuff like that I think that's
what really makes me feel like I'm part
of the story for me if I'm just moving
the character from point A to point B
changes the story then it seems a it
ruins that a lot of opportunity to make
something even further
awesome so I really really enjoy this
game for for many other reasons so she's
like this one now we're gonna have a
date with that Indian guy while looking
at how often can you say that look I
know you don't want to talk about it but
I'm gonna bring it up anything I think
you saw it pretty well so the entity
your father knew the spirit it's not the
first time he's kind of in it yet so has
always been here it comes at night and
steal Souls the old ones used to say
it's a curse the price our tribe had to
pay for living on these lands
doesn't spirit come every night it'll
come from many nights and then it won't
show up from once interests it always
ends up coming back my turn to ask you
some questions no what are you really
doing out here in the middle of the
desert it feels like you're running away
from something
truth I guess I'm just trying to forget
you know make a new start
maybe I'm just running away from me
you're like us how you also have your
dark secret don't you Tony you guess he
can say that I am
I have to tell you something what really
I thought you were gonna be a vet
evasive like all the other answers hey
thank you we hear how is he shot the bad
boy shot that seems the language Oh
sounds like he's extremely bored when
you talk more there's no water at the
ranch stuff the most of you up with the
well gonna have a look on my way back I
can go take a look if you want I don't
know if you'll be able to do much oh
thanks again where's the well you know
where it is it's over there he's got a
windmill should be hard to find
well I'll see you back at the ranch
okay later we're gonna use our
superpowers and make everyone happy I
love this scenery no let's say in a
place like this
all right Hitler let's get on you come
on he has the same haircut what do you
want for me I'm just saying it's a nice
name just okay fine I'll call him
something out how about a ski that's a
good name right came out with it all by
myself
okay ash ash skate you need to go a
little faster yeah yeah go
oh yeah Ashgate nice nice
it really feels like the life's of us
you remember their horse riding part
alright here we are
so how did the mountains become like
that
it's it from all the sandstorms it just
build up so how do we get off em again
oh there's a lot of stuff stuck up there
maybe maybe our little friend can help
us for that I'm on it
Joey I got you
and that was easier oh so that's
everyone's okay well that was easier
than you can say macaroni and cheese
balls oh they're so [ __ ] creepy
[Music]
should we go over there hey
oi oi
but it's love a baby don't go in there
Jody it's gonna be mainstays
[Music]
Jody this is not your business
Oh
I kind of want to get out of this place
right now actually
Wow
but but it wasn't me
is that the same ashes that's before oh
it was nothing but it seemed so real
and the line is still there what did he
write crow crown
oh the last letter looking at my crown
yeah we got it thank you
well let's let's get our crown let's be
a princess
come here I mean Aashiqui hurry the [ __ ]
up
I wish again wasn't so linear it feels
so good to just beat it ride riding
around like this I guess it makes for
better gameplay I don't know
I usually don't care if games are linear
but I usually open water just makes me
losses [ __ ] it's beautiful
gorgeous love it I'm riding my hos
reminds me of a Shadow of the Colossus I
should feel like replaying that game
[ __ ] Nelson
is that what it is is this Ford crown
it seems like at a sitting maybe the
spirit killed or something like that
[Music]
maybe he just wants to hit on her
or maybe he wants to tell us all his
secret can you see anything I did yeah I
see that thing and I gotta say it looks
pretty awesome oh it's over can check
memories yeah okay cool
I'm so bad at these you come over here
and then you suck in there yes that
man's line huh
it looked like the spirits that are
attacking you so what do I know about
life right it's liquid I didn't
whoa it's so fast sometimes
okay here's something found it
[Music]
it keeps a good momentum when it cuts to
stupid parts like that where normally
you then make you walk or super to them
and then we're gonna I like that
are those are things from Harry Potter
how about you just go back I think
that's what you should do but what do I
know about life I mean they're letting
you stay there at least snip around and
other people's business but I guess we
got no choice do we ask you Iger just my
hair look fabulous Paris not really it
looks kind of racist man oh man I got a
new shampoo and everything that all you
ever do with your life didn't hear
shudders yeah whatever you got falling
back
no well then shut the [ __ ] up okay Fork
tree I've never even saw it maybe I
didn't find it for us well it seems like
it they want us to go here it's okay
can't change the camera angle so I'm
gonna assume we have to go here oh you
know
is this it is that what forked memes is
there more to this story than we
originally thought what is going on I
mean what the hell is going out sorry
how does a movie reference tell me which
one and win a cookie sitting here it
might be a bit molded I didn't find
we're gonna dig what are you doin ask
you you can't eat sad silly horse O'Shea
it's a good spits go with a skull what
about this stone we're wearing these
ritual masks
and finally
okay I'm skating
oh he's healthy
I wouldn't be doing that if I was her
but what do I know about life
you see reassembling something what is
going on with everything weird if one
missing this one has no talisman it's
the same blanket grandma house put it
around the baby's neck grandma help me I
didn't it's got to see what happened
grandma you don't need to see what
happened
Oh God
oh [ __ ] they open the rift Oh way too
fast I didn't understand I did they
opened the rifts
mix up no it's fine it's really nice
something's missing
a talisman on the grandma that's what my
favorite talismans depaul maybe hole or
something how about you don't show the
talismans DePaul and maybe you don't dig
up old graves oh look what you've done
you pissed him off and now you got to
pay the price is it me or does old
mountains look like dicks well look at
that I win on that thing it looks
awesome it's so real
like they're dancing
alright we got it right back
know what give me a broad day like we
try to get the car
you have to fight it Jodi I don't else
we can do my father told you you can't
fight a spirit this one came this one
come on grandma stop looking at your
iPad damn that looks not that great all
right grandma gotta find grandma oh he
went right past grandma
I know about the talisman my sense when
you're talking
plot twist who woulda thought
okay cool we got it chef nice hands for
being old gotta hand it to you get it ha
ha ha
[Music]
what is this
Etowah to care for they open the refuge
there every detail
that was
guy
five of them
and they all die
your ancestors they summoned Yates who
here they were lost full of hatred for
the white man green spirit again revenge
he was still hungry hungry for blood
yeah it so is back he's come to take our
lives
your ancestors through the guardians who
protect the house right they know it
well almost
to protect us from the evil that they
released by they brought that entity
here I mean there's got to be some way
to send it back to its own world
they used a ritual to open the paths
pretty sure this is a supplier so
remember the incantation ritual is lost
I saw the ritual in my vision I'll
prepare it and you can help me with the
incantation hurry
he's coming
we need to be five people really we can
do it that means either grandma poles
got to do it and I don't think grandma's
got what it takes
okay well we can use these it's not
gonna be that easy to light a fire in
front of this wind
okay we can use okay we're
gasoline will definitely work
it's fun it's what I always used to say
if gasoline ain't working you better
suck just nothing
careful now that's gasoline Jody you
don't want to lose your eyebrows
she was sunny
you can talk
[Applause]
she's back I just
okay
there was a happy happy guy I don't
remember which one was it
thanks instead are you [ __ ] kidding
me
okay thought you wanted me to do it it
was on there each of their lines you're
not to remember that [ __ ] gosh well
okay
I got
[Music]
Oh
no [ __ ]
why don't use Hitler
let's get Paul [ __ ] good but but what
about mega
yeah
[Music]
you're wondering why this camera is
shaking is because Edgar is biting the
Train
[Music]
hey you gotta money
I know it I know it I thought Billy
Billy not that transparent Regina go
back to your home go back to where
you're from
Oh technically I actually failed first
time I think I added it out don't worry
about it I mean I don't fail edit
mustn't edit
[Music]
thank you making out with my tripod Judy
he runs to Jody before it runs to
Grandma
see this tiny
oh [ __ ]
again oh yeah but I'm it's now my people
have buried our dead there for many
hundreds of years
oh gosh sounds like a like a great first
date Hey
so we did it huh we kill that evil
spirit and send it back home how about a
high five
I tickled your face insane hey it feels
good sometimes we got a good old face
tickle never know you know not ticklish
on your face
you want to bet didn't think so
didn't think so for one second what is
his horse doing here who's here already
the brother was he going most Awkward
horse riding ever
all right let's follow him
ah she she stole her black cat how dare
she
so if you fail with a spirit basically
like they'll just say thanks for trying
and we'll keep fighting it and nothing
really happens and then I was like
pissed off that it didn't work because I
didn't use items power correctly I don't
know friendly you're charged and let go
but I charge it and pull back and if you
do that it doesn't work you don't give a
[ __ ] do you
that's fine I'll just I'll just it's
beautiful that last long piece look at
that it's a totem pole
oh we're gonna bury grandma and Paul -
Paul died - no way I didn't realize that
Paul died now I feel stupid
keep the blanket it's a nice blanket
these are the bones of your ancestors
I'm sure they would have wanted to be
buried alongside their own people
well now the brothers can rebuild the
line that the spirit isn't there anymore
maybe they can get a girlfriend get some
potatoes farming you know potatoes are
pretty good they can make like french
fries potato chips cook them in the oven
put some battery mmm that's good that's
good mushroom soup could we really have
se temps I doubt it
how how would have yourself the other is
what she massage of his ancestors he's
happy where it is
do you think you can save him Russ I
don't think we came back and he was dead
like what was ooh that was fast very
well no one is blaming her except
herself
it's a beautiful place huh
are they gonna be there thanking her
he's like he's off nugget
am I supposed to say hi
and disappeared all we can climb here
hell yeah let's climb sorry sorry
yeah
all right what do we got in here
I don't know where to go
it is a similar Mont Oh
oh that's [ __ ] creepy so the monster
was like I didn't there was someone else
part of him huh damn damn
your decision is made you leaving
there's just things that I have to work
out all the sudden things from my past I
think I'm ready to face them now yeah I
did a lot for us Jodie for us and for
our people
well they don't find you're looking for
just come back here you'll always find a
home here
that's not even anything
meet me spending three days together
let's not get ahead of myself here
alright just I'll miss the sheep's does
anyone remember those
no no one remembers two heats it's fine
Asha he's gonna miss you oh there horsey
yeah I'm gonna miss actually more than
if time
[Music]
hey Jody whoa if that piece of junk to
me you just been walking it took me some
time but I managed to get it going again
take it it's yours man I was at least we
can do to thank you I guess
I mean I did kiss him on the lips it's
kind of gross all right Vicky nation put
it in gear start yet yeah I am way off
[ __ ] eyes
it's like Star Wars moment right here
shouldn't she be able to walk now I
thought I thought that was a point when
you die you get to be like yelling you
know awesome she still gets her [ __ ]
chair huh well hope you guys enjoyed
this episode leave a like if you did
how's that a lot I really appreciate it
I try to make this extra long takes me a
little extra time but I don't care
because it's a fun game to play so I'll
see you tomorrow and you you write in
the comments what you did last birthday
[Music]
what what was that door moving